so your goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday don't
recommend any changes
that you wouldn't suffer for if they
fail endurance is one of the tools you
have to deal with
chronic discomfort and pain
need motivation what to talk to him with
believe in asia top
my top 10
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you are
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best jordan
peterson and my take on his top 10 rules
for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one improve yourself
daily i've had clients many clients in
their 30s who are trying to this is more
true with women i would say a lot of
women who are very high achieving who
establish their career goals at 30 and
then
want to differentiate differentiate out
their life they want to have a husband
they want to have a family they're
trying to figure out how to do that and
one of the things i've noticed that
around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
particularities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you
make sense out of that is that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy
you
yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high
and i really mean that it's like and
we'll talk about that a little bit too
aim high but use as your control
yourself it's like so your goal is to
make today some tiny increment better
than yesterday and you can use better
you can define better yourself this
doesn't have to be some imposition of
external morality you know you know
where you're weak and insufficient where
you could improve you think okay well
this is what i'm like yesterday if i did
this little thing
things would be just
an increment better
and
well that's a great thing because you
get the ball rolling and
incremental improvement is unstoppable
you can actually implement it and it
starts to generate paredo distribution
like consequences it starts to compound
and i've seen that happen in people's
lives over and over and people write me
all the time and tell me that they're
doing that but i've seen that happen in
people's lives continually they make a
goal a goal that the goal should be
how could i conceive of my life so that
if i had that life it would clearly be
worth living so i wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful rule number two don't isolate
yourself you act out the things that you
would do when you're normal even when
you're depressed you know you don't want
to see people well it doesn't matter you
go see them because it's better than not
seeing them you know and you find when
you do see them that it's better it'll
go better than you think but you can't
isolate yourself and
you're anxious and so you want to avoid
you don't want to go out you'd rather
stay home and sit in the chair and just
sit there and like in a frozen position
it's like you can't do that you have to
go out and go grocery shopping and go
out and have coffee and all of those
things it doesn't matter whether you
enjoy them
it matters that you do them because
that's what you do that's what you do in
order to maintain your health rule
number three take responsibility don't
recommend any changes
that you wouldn't suffer for if they
failed
how's that
and that's the problem with large-scale
political action it's like well here's
how we should change things it's like
well they change them it's wallet it
fails it doesn't bother me it doesn't
hurt me i'm not involved in it it's like
you should be careful when you try to
change things to make sure you suffer
for your own stupidity of course rule
number four trudge forward head down
endurance
and that'll get you through bad times
that endurance it's it's it's such an
under
represented virtue that ability to
trudge forward under a
trudge forward unhappily under uh
unfairly burdensome load is a testament
to character if you can
and then it's something that should be
encouraged and
valued
so
you know i'm not making the claim that
people who are depressed who can't get
out of bed lack endurance some do and
some don't because depression comes in
very
varied
degrees of intensity and and you can be
laid out completely by depression
so i'm not
trying to make some arbitrary judgment
about who's got endurance and who hasn't
you can't do that from the outside but i
can say that
endurance is one of the tools you have
to deal with chronic discomfort and pain
you know and even if you have chronic
pain it's interesting because it's very
much allied with depression by the way
all of the research on chronic pain back
pain for example indicates and chronic
pain of all sorts is that
the more you allow your pain to render
you inactive
the worse the outcome including
exacerbation of the pain and depression
is a pain disorder and so that's very
much worth thinking about too it's like
move forward move forward
move forward
you know and if you need to talk to
somebody about what your plan is for the
day or the hour or the week then do that
as well and perhaps you also have to
help get the people around you to help a
bit i need a little bit of help getting
up in the morning i need to have
breakfast made for me so that all i do
when i get up in my in my terrible state
of fog and confusion and terrible
anxiety and depression is i have a
shower because that's what happens first
and then the next thing is i eat and
then that's better you're at least
you're out of bed and moving and that's
that's a start you know
so
and then you endure and hope
and that's how it is and you do the same
thing when someone in your family is
sick or when you're facing a death all
of that it's like one bloody foot in
front of the other
up the hill
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief the sign
says it can take up to 200 254 days of
consecutive action for the habit to
stick that's what i want for you so i've
designed a custom free program we're
going to send you an unlisted video for
the next 254 days to shift your
confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you have to treat yourself
like you matter
because if you don't then you don't take
care of yourself and you become vengeful
oh no you're okay you should feel good
about yourself like you're you're fine
the way you are it's like you think well
that's a calming message for people it's
like no it's not rule number five have a
why you can ask yourself that question
what would make this worthwhile
i quote ninja i think in that chapter he
said he who has a why can bear almost
any how
that's a lovely line man i mean it's a
lovely line and it's really worth
thinking about so you think well
how do i manage all this misery and
suffering and futility it's like well i
need to figure out what i would have to
do in order to make that clearly
worthwhile and so then you have your
goal and then you think well i need to
move towards that incrementally because
i'm kind of useless and can only do so
much and maybe not even that and but all
i have to do is be a little bit better
than my
my miserable self yesterday
and that'll propel you forward very
rapidly and and you can succeed at it
which is also really lovely because why
not set yourself up for success you know
because otherwise you droop around like
a number 10 lobster and you know that's
just not good you get all pinchy when
that happens and it's not a good thing
rule number six store up food for the
future we discovered that we could let
go of something we value in the present
and we would gain something we value
even more in the future we acted that
out dramatically in all sorts of strange
ways over thousands and thousands of
years before it was
formalizable psychologically but it's a
massive discovery i can forego
gratification
in a particular way
and benefit in the future so i can share
the proceeds of my hunt
and i store up future food in the form
of reputation
and the favors i've owed i'm owed now by
other people
it's a massive discovery rule number
seven be truthful one of the things i've
learned
if you're
if you have a dispute with someone
and
it needs to be settled and maybe they
need to change more than you and that's
not always the case because sometimes
the settling requires change on your
part but let's say that
they have to be defeated in some sense
in comparison to you you don't want to
defeat them any more than necessary you
know it's like you don't knock your
opponent to the ground and then jump up
and down on them three or four times in
in triumph you know you you
you
you pin them and let and then let them
up
minimal
necessary force because any more than
that just produces a counter reaction
and so
and i guess the other thing is too is my
motivation
when i'm engaged let's say in these
discussions is that i'm not trying to
win the argument
i'm not trying to win
i'm trying to say what i think as
clearly as i can
and there is
there might be an element
there might be one of the consequences
of that might be
what appears to be a victory but
the right victory is the victory for
your ability to articulate what you
believe
and that's what i'm trying to do and so
that's another reason
to stay composed is like well okay
this person is just throwing a curveball
at me it's like all right so
well
i could be thinking well i don't want to
be undermined by that and i don't want
to make a fool of myself and i don't
want to be put on the spot and of course
all those things are true
but mostly what i'm thinking about is
okay well now i've got that question
i want to answer as truthfully as i
possibly can
what do i think about what was just said
and i'm not calculating the outcome
i'm assuming this is a mark of faith
right this is the faith that
that that people have talked about
being
something that
has to be manifested necessarily we've
been talking about this since the dawn
of time what's the faith
the faith is that if you
say what you believe to be true
then whatever happens is the best thing
that could have happened
and i believe that
so that's and i really believe it
partly because i believe that if you're
deceitful which is the opposite of that
or manipulative or malicious or
malevolent
but maybe primarily manipulative
then what you're acting out is your
belief that deceit will
bring victory and i just don't believe
that at all i i just i think it's a
preposterous claim
and so if deceit won't bring victory
then truth is what brings victory if
there is such a thing as truth
and there's certainly such a thing as
deceit so there must be such a thing as
truth
and so
and some of it's just curiosity too it's
like well i'm going to say what i think
and see what happens that's an adventure
you know that's the adventure of your
life
really and you don't want to miss that
because
that's what you've got in your life is
for it to be an adventure
it's not an easy
road you know it's a stormy sea
and
what you have is the adventure of
contending with god in the waves that's
what you have
and
the way you do that is with truth
and
then that sort of takes you out of the
immediacy of the conflict
whoever it is that the conflict with
whoever it is that you're talking to
you're trying to ally yourself with
something that's
deeper and more profound
and more lasting rule number eight do
what's meaningful do what is meaningful
not what is expedient and
to to view the world as a place of
resources that can be delivered to you
it's in some sense to be expedient is to
take the short term
it's to take the approach of short-term
gratification something like that yes
self-centered it's materialistic too
well it is materialistic but it's also
it's also it's not optimal and it's it's
not wise and the reason for that is is
that it actually turns out like if we're
going to have if we had a continuing
relationship
i would want to try to do a little bit
more for you than you do for me and i
could do that even purely selfishly say
because if i did a little bit more for
you than you did for me you would want
to keep interacting with me rule number
nine appreciate people
i appreciate you guys and i'll tell you
man if you want to have a good
relationship with someone that's one
thing you don't do you open your bloody
eyes and if they do something that you
would like them to do again
then you
tell them how much you appreciated the
fact that that happened and you hope
that it replicates you know you see
that that's if there's one thing you can
take away from tonight's lecture that's
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know watch and when people do
something that they should do more of
say look i saw that you did this
specific thing i saw that it took some
effort here's what it meant here's
here's how i observed it's like keep
that up and man if you love someone you
do that to them that's that's
encouragement that's such a great thing
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is have
hope the positive emotion that we find
sustaining
is experienced in relationship to an
unachieved goal
it's hope that drives us forward we want
something and if we see ourself moving
towards that
then
we're we're in the grip of the positive
emotion that we find sustaining it isn't
the attainment attainment is satiating
attainment shuts down the system that
has been striving for that particular
object of attainment if you're hungry
and you eat you stop being hungry now
that's good because the hunger is gone
but that whole frame
disappears
you can no longer strive within that
frame
and you need a new frame to strive
towards
and so technically and this is well
established as far as i'm concerned we
even know the drugs that people abuse
cocaine let's say amphetamines the ones
that are potent
sources of positive emotion
activate the system that regulates our
emotional response to evidence that
we're moving towards a desired goal
so cocaine for example
is an exhilarating drug it makes you
feel that things are worthwhile because
it hijacks the system that does make
indicate that things are worthwhile
so
this is deeply this this striving aspect
is deeply rooted in in our in our
biology
for obvious reasons
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
it is my firm belief that each of us
have a responsibility to set the world
right in the manner that we are able to
and that that is a fundamental
that's a fundamental import
i really believe in some sense it's of
cosmic import
in the same way that consciousness
itself is of cosmic import and
consciousness reflects being itself you
write in the book
there is no faith and no courage and no
sacrifice in doing what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers
because they're too afraid to take risks
and pursue something meaningful well the
first thing i would say is
well you should be afraid of taking
risks and pursuing something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable it's like the first thing you
want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any
any permanent security outside of your
ability to contend and adapt it's the
same issue with children it's like
you're paying a price by sitting there
being miserable you might say well the
devil i know is better than the one i
don't it's like don't be so sure of that
the clock is ticking
and if you're miserable in your job now
and you change nothing in five years
you'll be much more miserable and you'll
be a lot older but isn't it the luxury
to pursue what is meaningful our viewers
have mortgages they have children yeah
they have payments and loans it's a
luxury to pursue because we lack the
resources well i don't think i don't
remember now i'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful and that
doesn't mean it's easy it might require
sacrifice if you need to change your job
too let's say you have uh family and and
and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free say well i don't
like my job i quit
that's no strategy but what you might
have to do is you think well this job is
killing my soul all right so what do i
have to do about that well i have to
look for another job well no one wants
to hire me it's like okay maybe you need
to educate yourself more maybe you need
to update your your curriculum vita your
resume maybe you need to overcome your
fear of being interviewed
maybe you need to sharpen your social
skills like you you have to think about
these things strategically if you're
going to switch careers you have to do
it like an intelligent responsible
person that might take you a couple of
years of
of effort i've dealt with hundreds of
people in my clinical and consulting
practice and we set a goal we develop a
vision and work towards it and it things
inevitably get better for people so it's
not a luxury it's it's difficult it's a
moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness it's it's not the pursuit
isn't for happiness well that isn't how
it is it's like we're built for struggle
us human beings
you're not after
the bubbles of bliss that dostoevsky
described in in notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have
also people that have extracted
unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures
and so and i'm not saying that in a
naive way i know perfectly well what
happens to people you know you're doing
fine in life and then you get cancer and
then six months later you're dead and
all the heroism in the world isn't going
to save you at that point but that's not
the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and content and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do compare yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today
because if you're comparing yourself to
someone else i mean first of all you
don't know very much about the life of
the person you're comparing yourself to
you don't know it you know it across all
of its dimensions
and second people are very different and
so comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful i guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more particular it
becomes increasingly less
useful
better to compare yourself to a previous
version of yourself and work for
improvement in that way life is
difficult and you cannot protect your
children
what you can do is prepare them and you
can prepare them to be strong and
courageous and
truthful and
resilient and reciprocal in their
interactions with other people and that
means you equip them for what life will
be which is at minimum a series of
difficult challenges and and often more
than that because of course people go
through very difficult times in their
lives and
a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to prevail
and so the primary your primary goal as
a parent apart from facilitating your
child's social desirability which is a
major
obligation on your part is to encourage
your children and to and i mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that
we don't even want to be protected from
those difficulties because a major part
of life and its meaning is
the
the challenge that comes with
confronting difficulties i said with
bill c-16 that i wouldn't speak the
language of the radical leftists because
i don't think that that language should
define the game but let's say it does so
here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game
and some of them win and they oppress
those who don't win so that's how we're
going to view the world okay now the
left is say okay well here's the
oppressed people the oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh i see so the game is ethnic identity
is it
it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose
that's the right wing version of
identity politics it's like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and i'm in my tribe
i'm not going to get all guilty and lose
i'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics spectrum
am i going to fall in do i want to go
with uh do i want to
go
do i want to be driven primarily by
compassion and
am i going to accept guilt for my
historical privilege so that's one
possibility and then i'm the oppressor
i'm the member of the oppressor group or
am i going to say no to hell with that
i'm just going to play to win well then
i'm going to go to the right it's like
well my sense is how about we don't play
either of those games and the reason we
shouldn't play them is well the soviets
played the left-wing game and like
killed
who knows how many tens of millions of
people you can't even count it
accurately the estimates range from 20
to 100 million those are pretty big
error bars and the maoists maybe a
hundred million certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well and
then there's the nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like what do we want to
play that game
see what i've been trying to do really
what i've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so i have a
book rule in there says set your house
in perfect order before you criticize
the world and it's a
very dark chapter about the motivations
of the columbine high school killers and
this other guy named carl panzram who
was a serial rapist and arsonist and
murderer and these he wrote an
autobiography and the columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful
terrible
and
well i'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim
because we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well it's everyone's
a victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly i got
attracted to christian imagery at least
in part
um because there's an idea in
christianity that you should pick up
your god cross and like walk up the hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily and try to
transform as a consequence
that's the right answer it's the right
answer because the rest of it is
tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
the baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just a
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you dual familial
and social harmony
that's what i want people say that to me
and you know i don't think it's exactly
right
there's there's a line in the old
testament the fear of god is the
beginning of wisdom and i think it's
more like that it's not that i'm
courageous it's that i'm afraid of the
right things
so when i made my videos it wasn't like
that didn't make me nervous
but
i was less nervous about going back to
bed and not saying what i had to say
that i was about making the videos
because i know where this is going
i don't want to go there and so
it's it's not so much courage it's that
it's a matter of
i it's it's it's less risky
to say something
than to remain silent when you know
there's something to be said i know that
to be the case
and so lots of times in life it's like
there's no pathway forward that's going
to shield you from risk you get to pick
this risk or you get to pick this risk
and i think i picked the lesser risk and
that might be wise but i'm not so sure
it's courageous you don't tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail
you say here's something worth going
after here's a step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone
you're expanding your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay i need to set a
goal but i need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it then you got then you've
got it perfectly because it's not so
high that it's grandiose or impossible
that you fail necessarily and then
justify your bitterness it's like well i
could do well because that happens to
people happens all the time yeah it's
like this all the time you know it's
like it's yes exactly well i set a goal
and i didn't attain it so i'm not going
to set any more goals right it's like no
you set a goal that was inappropriate
for the time frame
that's right you didn't calibrate it
properly and and you're playing a trick
on yourself because you wanted to fail
so that you could justify not having to
try
and being a victim yeah which is helpful
you're still going to be a victim it's
like there's no way out of that man
so you know because life is this life is
a challenge that in some sense can't be
surmounted so there's no way out of your
problem not only do you have to move
from point a to b in life but point a is
often a very difficult place to be
because we're fragile and bounded and
mortal and limited and because we know
that and so one of the
implications of that as many great
religious traditions are at pains to
illustrate or demonstrate or proclaim
is that life is essentially suffering
and i believe that to be a fundamental
truth but
but perhaps not the most fundamental
truth because i think the most
fundamental truth is that despite the
fact that life is suffering people can
transcend that and partly the way they
transcend that is by pursuing things of
value and so that if there is no value
proposition at hand then you have no
meaning
to justify the difficult conditions of
your life and that's brutally difficult
for people you know nietzsche said
he who has a
why can bear any how
and you see and i've certainly seen this
as a clinical practitioner that people
who have no purpose in their life
are embittered by the difficulties of
their life and they become first bitter
and then resentful and then revengeful
and then cruel and there's plenty of
places to go past cruel that's just
where you start if you're really on a
downhill path the more radical the
necessary change the more pain that
accompanies it
like the more opportunity as well
but and a lot of what we learn we learn
painfully and so it's not surprising
that people shrink away from learning we
learn in pain and anxiety very
frequently everyone knows that like the
things that really that you really
learned in life it's like it was no joy
man like it took you out
and so the fact that people flee from
that is hardly surprising
but it doesn't help that's the thing it
just stores up the catastrophe for later
and so the better
the better
idea is to eat a little poison every day
so that you don't have to overdose in a
month it's something like that
and it is the case that i think because
you don't you aren't forced to first of
all you don't learn unless you're forced
to learn i know there's alternatives to
that there's the voluntary search for
knowledge and that's a fine thing and
that is an antidote to this but
apart from that
speaking more
practically
you tend not to learn unless you're
forced to learn and it's and what you
tend to learn by force are difficult
lessons
and so people are very prone to not
to not seek that out
it's not surprising
but it's because they don't understand
the consequences very well
you know you you
it's because maybe it's because they're
convinced that there's some way of
forestalling the necessary learning
and there isn't
any way of forestalling it all you do is
make it worse in the future you make
yourself smaller and you make the lesson
harder
and so that's why in so many religious
doctrines there's emphasis on humility
you know and humility isn't to debase
yourself
it's to understand that
you don't know enough so that your life
isn't going to be miserable
and so every chance you get to grab
something new that will help you along
your way you should take it as fast as
you can but you have to have a very
tragic
i would say view of reality and also a
harsh one because it's not just tragedy
it's also malevolence you have to
understand that those are waiting for
you and
that makes you desperate enough to learn
and that might be make you desperate
enough to fall out of your ideology
but
that's that's a hard way of looking at
the world
it beats living through it though one of
the things i've been talking to my
audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying um
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it um
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
uh exaggerated by as a consequence of
human failing as a consequence of
malevolence and betrayal and
self-betrayal and deceit and all those
things that we do to each other and
ourselves that we know that aren't good
that amplifies the suffering that's sort
of the baseline against which you have
to work and and and it's contemplation
of that often that makes people hopeless
and depressed and anxious and
overwhelmed and all of that and and they
have the reasons
but you need something to put
up against that
and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness different than
happiness that's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've justified you've
justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
how you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or yeah or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that and so
if you think about the times when you're
at peace with yourself with regards to
how you're conducting yourself in the
world it's almost always conditions
under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt i think that you can
experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that you
know we kind of have this idea that
while you're free as a child and then
you
let me see if i can if i can put this
properly
that you have a certain delightful
wonderful positive freedom as a child
and then that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that
you have a lot of potential as a child
but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined
and discipline is a matter of the
imposition of order and the order is
necessary especially for people who are
hopeless and nihilistic and lots of
people are hopeless and nihilistic way
more people than you think and part of
that is because no one's ever really
encouraged them and so the book is in
part a matter of encouragement it's like
lay yourself lay a disciplinary
structure on yourself get the chaos in
in in check and then you can move
towards a state that's freer because
it's disciplined first like look if
you're going to become a concert pianist
there's going to be several thousand
hours of extraordinarily disciplined
practice that's the imposition of order
on your potential let's say but what
comes out of that is a much grander
freedom your best bet is truth
but that doesn't necessarily mean that's
always going to do the trick
right i mean sometimes
you go fight a dragon and it eats you
and if the
if you being eaten wasn't a real
possibility
it wouldn't be a real fight
and so you see people like i've seen
people
in my clinical practice sometimes
i had one client in particular who was
undergoing a particularly vicious
divorce with someone who was really
seriously inclined to take him out and
would do pretty much everything at her
disposal to do so
and i strategized with him for about
three years
and we did everything like and hyper
carefully he was a very conscientious
and diligent person and he
put into practice everything that we
discussed and strategized and he still
pretty much he got backed into a corner
so hard that i didn't know how to help
him anymore
so
i would say however that he like he was
a very truthful person throughout that
and one thing he did do was
part of it was a custody battle
and he did
manage despite his decline
in consequence of being repeatedly
cornered i would say he did manage to
establish what i think was a lasting
relationship with his kids
so he might have got
enough out of what he did to justify it
even though
the whole landscape was pretty
awful
i think that
not lying is your best bet
but
life is hard and people get run over and
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to emerge in any obvious sense
triumphant
but if you take the alternative path
path especially when you're
facing severe tribulations let's say and
you complicate those with deceit you can
be sure that whatever tragedy that
you're confronting is going to turn into
not only tragedy but something very much
akin to hell
and so you might be able to at least
minimize the degree of suffering even if
you can't
overcome it or transcend it well before
the political stuff blew up i had a
million views on youtube which is
nothing a million of anything is a lot
but then when the political scandal
started to break yeah then people came
for them but stayed for the content and
so and that's been really useful yeah
well it's well and it's not that
surprising well you know because of what
you do it's like
peop there's a great hunger for
information that is
practical and useful and
that helps people
find meaning in their lives and orient
themselves there's a great hunger for
that and most of my lectures were
derived from
solid psychology some of it experimental
some of it biological some of it from
from from the domains of neuroscience a
lot of it from great clinicians it's not
surprising that people find it helpful
because well great clinicians were great
because they were really helpful and so
to distill that and to offer it to
people in a digestible form to have that
have a good effect on them well that's
that's what you'd expect that's what the
whole discipline is about and so that's
been that's been great this
circumambulation that jung talked about
was this
continual
will return to this this continual
circling in some sense of who you could
be you might notice for example that
there are themes in your life you know
when you go back across your experiences
you see you kind of have your typical
experience that sort of repeats itself
and there might be variation on it like
a musical theme but it's it's like
you're circling yourself and getting
closer to yourself as you move across
time that's the circumambulation now you
remember that for a second we'll go back
to it okay so imagine that something
glimmers before you it's an interest
that's dawning and you decide well first
of all you're paralyzed you think well
how do i know if i should pursue that
it's probably a stupid idea and the
proper response to that is you're right
it probably is a stupid idea because
almost all ideas are stupid and so the
the probability that as you move forward
on your adventure that you're going to
get it right the first time is zero it's
just not going to happen and so then you
might think well maybe i'll just wait
around until i get the right idea and
which people do right so they're like 40
year old 13 year olds which is not a
good idea so they wait around until it's
waiting for godot until they finally got
it right but the problem is you're too
stupid to know when you've got it right
so waiting around isn't going to help
because even if it the perfect
opportunity manifested itself to you in
your incomplete form the probability
that you would recognize it as the
perfect opportunity is zero you might
even think it's the worst possible idea
that you've ever heard of anywhere
highly likely highly likely so
so you have there's
nietzsche called that a will to
stupidity which i really liked so
because he thought of stupidity as being
it
you know it's it's
you have to take it into account
fundamentally and work with it and so
and so you can take these tentative
steps on your
pathway to destiny and you can assume
that you're going to do it badly and
that's really useful because you don't
have to beat yourself up it's pretty
easy to do it badly
but the thing is it's way better to do
it badly than not to do it at all you
start your path and you think that
you're heading you know towards your
star
and so you go in that direction and then
because
you're here the world looks a particular
way but then when you move here
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having
made that voyage and so what that means
is that now that thing that glimmers in
front of you is going to have shifted
its location because you weren't very
good at specifying it to begin with and
now that you're a little sharper and
more focused than you were
it's it's going to reveal itself with
more accuracy to you and so then you
have to take a
you know it's almost like 180 degree
reversal but it isn't because you know
you've
i mean you've gone this far and that's a
long ways to get that far
but that's a lot farther than
you would be if you just stayed where
you were waiting
and so it doesn't matter that you
overshoot
continually
because as you overshoot
even if you don't learn what you should
have done you're going to continually
learn what you shouldn't keep doing
and if you learn enough about what you
shouldn't keep doing then
that's tantamount at some point to
learning at the same time what you
should be doing
so it's okay
so it's like this
now what's cool about it though i think
is that as you progress the
degree of overshooting starts to decline
right and that we know that there's
nothing hypothetical about that as you
learn a new skill like even to play play
a song on the piano for example you
overshoot madly you're making all sorts
of mistakes to begin with and then the
mistakes
they they disappear the fact that you're
full of faults doesn't mean you have to
stop
and thank god for that that's a really
useful thing
and the fact that you're full of faults
doesn't mean that you can't learn
and so you can posit an ideal and you're
going to be wrong about it but it
doesn't matter because what you're right
about is positing the ideal moving
towards it if the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly well first
surprise surprise because like what are
you going to do that's perfect so
it doesn't matter that it's imperf
imperfect it just matters that you do it
and that you move forward so that's
really that's really positive news as
far as i'm concerned because you can
actually do that right you can do it
badly anyone can do that so that's
that's useful i'm incredibly nervous to
uh
talk in front of you because you've got
to be one of the most formidable people
that i've ever
heard of or ever listened to or ever
seen so
my question is
again you're one of the best
communicators that i've ever listened to
if i could be
half as good
at you or at communicating as you are
i would be set how can i teach myself to
do that
practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things is
helps to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes
maybe you could steal 15 minutes and do
it every day
but if you do that for 10 years you
really straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at university because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
ten times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side
well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group there's a
bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when i talk to a
group i always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there
there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell
if they're engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so one thing is to
to have something to say
yeah
but the next thing is pay attention to
who you're talking to
because unless you're
very badly socialized and that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know
and
well i mean i don't know you very well
but at first but on first sight
you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about it you're actually
engaged in a conversation with an
audience even if they're not
talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or
and you can you can pull all that in and
and and use it to govern
the level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing i would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well i
could buttress that to some degree
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate i don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter i mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so
the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges i think
i don't know if they've forgotten it but
they don't do a very good job of
marketing it's like what's the use of a
bachelor's degree a bachelor of arts
it's like well
you can think
you can write
you can speak
you've read something
it's like
the economic value that is incalculable
the people that i've watched in my life
who've been
spectacularly successful are
they have skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're sick it doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice oh yes chapter nine is assume
that the person you are listening to
might know something you don't
this is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms conversation
takes
it's a chapter about humility
and it's a chapter about listening and
the humility element is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions
supporting humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to
then then what you don't know can start
to be your friend you see people are
very defensive about what they know and
for the reasons we've already discussed
but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough
and so
what that means is that every time you
encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how i'm wrong it's like
great like maybe i had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
i'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then i wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning
and then it's deeper than that it's do
you want to be
the the tyrannical king who's already
got everything figured out or do you
want to be the continually transforming
hero or fool for that matter who's
getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's
humble enough to make friends with what
he or she doesn't know and to listen
when people talk and
listening is a transformative exercise
like if if you listen to the people in
your life for example if you actually
listen to them they'll tell you what's
wrong with them and how to fix it and
what they want they can't even help it
if you start listening because people
are so shocked if you actually listen to
them that
they tell you all the sorts of things
that they might not have even intended
to things they don't even know and then
you can
you can work with that but our topic
is
the rising tide
of compelled speech
in canada
[Music]
uh
hey
that's pure narcissism at work by the
way
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know to hijack
to hijack an event like this
that other people put time and effort
into and to
use they their their civility of the
crowd and the civility of the organizers
as an excuse to
blatantly yell out your ill-informed
opinions is no way to conduct a civil
dialogue these people
are not your friends
let me see you know
[Music]
that's
that
that and mark my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates
right
yeah that's all i'll tell you again too
that uses in kuwait
[Music]
what would you call it in kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of
their argument
and there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you
so keep that in mind
it's not amusing there's nothing to it
there's nothing for it the thing that's
also quite appalling is that
there's no evidence whatsoever that the
people who are conducting these protests
know what it is that they're protesting
against you know i was in
[Applause]
[Music]
i
i was in the midst of a discussion
attempting to make the case that
it's freedom of speech that's
that is what people who have nothing
still have right so if you look at the
tyrannical structure of our society
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication
everyone knows that
it's the people at the bottom who have
the right to say what they think however
badly they say it that enables them to
get a toehold into the system and to and
to make their suffering known that's
what freedom of speech is for
and so like what's the protest against
that and i'll tell you you know that the
radical neo-marxist types they speak the
language of power and that's what
they're speaking right now and if you
want to live in a world where everyone
speaks the language of power then just
let them do what they're doing and see
what happens i wouldn't recommend it
it's not a pretty road and you're all in
a position you're on a situation in your
life now where you have to make
decisions about this sorts of things
like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be i do believe
it's the case because i've watched
people do very difficult things like
people who work in palliative care
awards so all they're ever dealing with
is pain and death right and they can do
it
they get up in the morning they go to
work and they take care of those people
they lose people on a weekly basis and
yet they can do it and what that shows
is that if you
turn around and you confront the
suffering voluntarily you find out that
you are way tougher than you think it's
not that life is better than you think
life is as harsh as you think it might
even be worse but you are way tougher
than you think if you turn around and
confront it and so then what you
discover is that there's a spirit within
you that pursues some that can pursue
something meaningful that has the
resilience and the strength to contend
properly with the catastrophe of
existence without becoming bitter that's
actually the central so
and then i would say that's one of the
central themes of 12 rules for life is
that make no mistake about it like
the first noble truth of buddhism life
is suffering this is true and it's worse
than that because it's suffering
contaminated by malevolence that's the
baseline but and so that's very
pessimistic but the optimistic part is
that you are so tough you can actually
not only deal with that you can improve
it it's like oh well that's a horrible
situation but it turns out that i'm
armed for the task well that's that's a
great thing for people to know and i do
believe i think the fact that we're
armed for the task is even more true
than the fact that life is catastrophe
contaminated by malevolence we're
stronger than things are terrible so and
things are pretty terrible so that means
we're pretty damn strong wow yes it's a
very good thing to know and it's not
naive optimism it's a very different
thing it's like no things are terrible
they're brutal and you are so tough you
can't believe it you love to quote this
line this nietzsche line that um anyone
who has a y to live for can endure
almost anyhow
what's your why what is driving you you
see when people read history they either
read it as a detached observer or they
tend to read it as
well maybe the heroic
the heroic protagonist people like to
imagine that they would be schindler in
schindler's list but that's wrong
so because the probability that you'll
be the perpetrator is much higher
especially merely the perpetrator who's
in constant silence when silence is not
the appropriate thing
so i wanted to having figured out what
constituted hell and the pathway to that
which would be
i suppose the cowardice that produces
the cowardice and resentment that
produces either
complicitness in those
events or failure to oppose them when
they emerge
i wanted to understand what the opposite
of that was
because i think that's what needs to be
learned from what happened in the 20th
century and so that's why i wrote maps
of meaning was to understand that and to
lay out what the opposite was
and then that turned out to be extremely
helpful to me and then to the people i
started to teach about that because
it's useful to know what the opposite of
hell is
and
i've been teaching those things to
people since 1993 such 25 years and the
response from the students has always
been the same sort of response that i'm
getting now
um absent some of the negative uh
characterizations let's say which which
have emerged for for particular reasons
but the students have always said one of
two things
and and this is the vast majority of
them this isn't cherry picked responses
it's been the same everywhere
um
they tell me and this is the same
response i get from my audiences now too
is they say you've
given me words to explain things to
explain and understand things that i
always knew to be true
or
i was in a very dark place for one of
the seven reasons that people might be
in a dark place
alcohol or drugs or failure of
relationships or lack of vision or
nihilism or
or hopelessness or depression or anxiety
and all the pitfalls that people can
encounter and
i've been developing a vision for my
life and trying to adopt responsibility
and trying to be careful with what i say
and things are way better
and that's what drives me what's your
definition of greatness
[Music]
well greatness is what reveals itself
when you
when you attempt to
formulate when you attempt to
carefully articulate and live out what
you believe to be true
it just happens
because there isn't anything more
powerful than truth
right that's the antidote to suffering
truth
right
so it's a strange thing because you
think well yeah it produces a lot of
suffering too it's like yeah in the
short term they say do you believe in
god let's say and my response to that
always is well i don't know what you
mean when you ask me that question so i
don't know how to answer it i don't know
what you mean by believe but i can tell
you something that i believe
and i would say this is a way of
speaking symbolically
i do believe so i was thinking the other
day a week ago i was thinking about this
this little fantasy that entered my mind
i was thinking about saint joseph's
oratorio in montreal and saint joseph's
oratorio is a very large religious
building it's one of the biggest
cathedral-like structures in the world
and it's set on the hill on mount royal
and it's set up where it can catch the
sun you know so it's an image of the
heavenly city on the hill right it's an
image of the structures that we strive
to create that's what it is independent
of its specifically christian or
religious function that's what it stands
for symbolically okay so it's the city
on the hill it's it's what we're
striving towards when we walk uphill
in life okay now the way the the
oratorio is structured there's hundreds
of steps leading to it up front and in
the early part of the 20th century a lot
of people who had physical disabilities
came there and they struggled up the
step on their crutches and many of them
left their crutches in the oratorio you
can see hundreds of them if you go there
it's quite an interesting site
and i was thinking about that and i was
thinking about what that meant and this
is what it means it means that
you know everyone has their disabilities
let's say and i know that some people
are far more
terribly affected than other people i'm
perfectly aware of that but the question
is what do you do about that and what
you do is you you set yourself up on
your crutches and you struggle up the
bloody hill that's what you do and you
struggle up the hill towards the kingdom
of god that's what you do because the
alternative is to descend into the abyss
that's the alternative and then so to
say well do you believe it's like i
believe that you should struggle uphill
towards the city of god on your crutches
that's what you should do
that's the opposite of the descent into
the abyss
and so that's that's at the foundation
of our civilization that idea well
argue with it if you will see if you can
figure out why that's not an acceptable
idea maybe you should help someone
struggle up the hill perhaps you should
you know you can lend a hand to someone
although you don't want to take the
burden away from them entirely because
there's something noble about struggling
up the hill right there's something
that's adventure that's the call to
proper being
it's like well we don't need to forget
this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there since time
immemorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea that's
what gives your life not happiness
forget about that
if it comes well great accept it i made
a decision when the computers started to
become omnipresent and so that would
have been about 1993 that i was going to
spend a year and that was the first year
that i was teaching in boston
pretty much doing nothing but figuring
out how
intel 486s worked
and it meant there was a lot of other
things that i had to put on hold but i
did become
a competent computer user and i was i'm
pretty fast but
you know my son it's just annoying as
hell to watch him on the computer and on
the phone because and my graduate
students as well because they're so much
faster than me that it's not even funny
and i'm not really accustomed to being
slower than someone else in the room you
know if i had children now the one thing
i would bloody well make sure that they
knew was how to use a computer how to
program man because if you're smart and
you can use a computer you are so much
smarter than you are if you're just
smart that it's not even funny you know
when you talk to people you see this in
silicon valley all the time you talk to
people who are expert computer users
they are so bloody powerful it is just
beyond belief
so and that that's going to do nothing
but
expand right because moore's law is not
dead and computers are doubling in power
every 18 months and and so and who the
hell knows where that's going to go i
don't know what percentage of human
effort is spent in counterproductive
activity you know i i'm i'm not an
absolute cynic about that but i mean
when i talk to undergraduates i ask them
you know how much
time do you waste every day
by your own
reckoning and it's somewhere between
five and eight hours you know it's a lot
of it's a lot of time well i usually
walk through i walk the stu students
through an economic analysis of that i
said well you know why don't you value
your time at 50 an hour and calculate
for yourself just exactly what you're
doing to your future by your inability
to discipline yourself it's worth
thinking through
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline
like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your day done by
the time other people haul their sorry
asses out of bed and so that's a massive
massive advantage look will ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 have non-proportional payoffs that's
part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly a
calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
it also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your calendar and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious make a plan you need a plan
for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
you need a vision of who you could be
what character you could have three to
five years out you can't go much farther
than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than
that subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a ten year goal but
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there